好
那各位同午安
那今天的話是我們的公文系統的承辦人的教育訓練
那我們在我們那個
我們這個陽明校區這邊呢
我們有兩個場次
那一個場次是今天下午的部分
那我們的教育訓練的部分
承辦人的部分分兩個主題
一個是基本功能的這一個基礎篇
一个基础篇
那明天早上
还有一堂是进阶的课程
是针对于一些
进阶的功能的部分
去做说明
那两个课程里面
中间都还是会特别去讲到
我们年度功能优化的项目
有哪一些
所以如果你是专门来听
公务系统今年度的部分
有新增什么的部分的话
那其实两天折一天来做
来做上课就可以了
那如果说是要针对于系统的操作
跟整体的功能
然后要来做相关的这一个询问
或是想要知道说
这整个操作什么部分
要来做一个学习的部分的话
那可能就要看一下
你本身对于功能系统
本身的了解程度到那一个状况
那因为今天的部分是基础的课程
所以会讲比较
基础面的东西
可能我们比较平常在用的一些
画面功能还有流程的部分
好
那我们就正式开始
那今天的部分是我们承办教育训练
那是我们的基础编
那今天的课程就正式开始
那首先要说明的部分的话
是系统从哪边去做一个登录的动作
那学校的部分的话
我们有跟学校的单一路口网去做整合
那我们这边就是要请各位同仁
登录到学校的单一路口网
然后我们可以点左侧的这一个功能列表
左側這邊有功能列表
然後這邊可以看到我們有從物的這一塊的分頁選到這一塊的分之后呢找到我们的公文签和其他案关系统那我们学校的这个单一路口
右边有这一个
可以做标示我的最爱跟自理的这个功能
所以如果说假设
你们有需要的话
可以来做这样的标示跟自理的动作
那当你点这一个系统的按钮之后呢
系统就会帮你做身份的验证
从你单一入口网登录之后
你就会有个身份的资料
那会跟公文系统去做身份的验证
那系统就会帮你导入到公文系统里面
你的这一个账号的部分
所以在公文系统本身
你们是不用再做登录的动作
那特别提一下
如果说假设您刚好是新进的同仁的部分的话
那可能会有一个状况是必须说明一下
是入口网的账号申请完之后
不代表公文系统的账号也一定会有
它是两个分开的
只是中间有做整合
你们不用再做输入账密的动作
所以如果也有可能有一个状况
是你从这个入口网的连接
连到公文系统之后
发现是没有办法登录进去的
那这样状况很有可能
就是你公文系统的账号
是还没有开启的部分
那相关的程序
就是一学校里面的一个申请程序
去做申请的动作
这个部分我们就没有在课堂上去做说明
好
那這個是登錄的部分
那登錄的部分了之後呢
原則上你可以看到我們目前解報
左手邊的這一個首頁的畫面
那如果說假設您是第一次用系統
那原則上系統呢
它會跳出一個紅色的視窗
也是你們現在看到紅色的畫面
它叫你輕易安裝千張元件
那這個千張元件的功能呢
它是會用在我們未來線上線盒的功文
跟一些相关的附件管理
会用到的一个小程式
这个一定要装
不然没有办法用
那安装的方式很简单
如果说你的电脑
是完全没有用过的话
跳出这个画面之后
帮我点确定
点确定之后
到你的电脑的
它基本上就会帮你下载下来
到你电脑的下载区域
然后点两下打开去安装
基本上大概95%以上
都不会有问题
那如果说假设安装上有问题的话
可能就是可以再找
文书单位这边协助
可以排除或者假设真的不能排除的话
那可能他会再请我们厂商这边去做协助的动作然后再来这边有一件事情要跟各位说明一下是千张元件的部分的话它本身有一个凭证那为了安全性的凭证的部分的话
它会需要做每年的更新
那这个更新的部分
各位也不用担心说
就是我未来每年一到要重新去做安装
系统本身千张元件
在原本的凭证有效期的期限内
我们会去签发下一个年度的凭证
那会帮学校这边去做更新
所以原则上凭证是可以做到自动更新的效果
但是这个前提是
你有在那个有效期限内去做更新
你只要登录系统
其实系统就会帮你做背景的处理
你不用做过多的动作
除非你的电脑真的在更新的过程有什么状况
所以这边的话要跟各位讲的是说
我们大概都是
因为现在凭证大概都是一年为周期
那原则上的话
大概会在六七月的时候会公告
那随着时间提前的话
在凭证到期之前我们都会提前公告
也会提前部署到我们系统上
所以这个部署上去之后
大家大概可能会有两到三个礼拜的时间
然后可以去做更新的动作
你只要登录到系统里面
系统就会帮你做背景的更新
那这个要麻烦大家再帮我注意一下公告的部分
那公告在哪里
就是看我们下面这张图
你登录的时候
首页的话
左侧这个区块
是我们的代办事项的快速键的按钮
它这个是icon
都是可以连接到各个资料夹
中间这一块的话是公文查询夹
它这边告诉你
你有什么相关的夹子的键数
一个快速统计
右边这一块红色的框框
这个部分就是公告区
那公告区的部分
麻烦如果说我们有登录的情况之下
再稍微注意一下这个公告部分
因为公告有时候会说明说有发布一些新的资讯
有可能会有系统维护
或者是一些相关资讯的公告
那包含像我们今天的教育训练
我们也是透过公告的方式
把线上的网址放在这个地方
让大家去连接
所以这个部分的话
有些相关的公告大家稍微注意一下
这个部分是我们第一个步骤
安装签章元件
那安装签章元件就点完之后
它自己会安装
不用做什么特别复杂的程序
那理论上它安装起来之后
你之後系統就可以正常做使用
然後元件的部分
它是安裝在你自己的那一台電腦
所以假設如果您的那個工作身份比較特殊可能需要跨單位有時候可能在A電腦用有時候可能在B電腦用公文系統的話那兩台電腦都要裝那兩台電腦都是要裝千張元件
但是帳號部分的話是
你只要是一群正常管道的話
那其實在哪邊登入都沒關係
好這個部分的話是第一個步驟
安裝千張元件的部分
這邊補充說明一下
如果說系統沒有調出這個畫面
我們在這個系統的這一個說明這裡
在你的左上角這一個名字
然後下面一個說明
這裡會有個檔案下載
我們也會把最新版本的元件放在上面
下載下載完之後
安裝也是可以
這個是我們的安裝元件的部分
好
這個是要維護我們的個人資料
那維護個人資訊的部分
我們剛剛這邊有看到
左上角的名字下面
剛剛是講的說明
右邊有個人
點開有個下拉式選單
第一個選項就是個人資訊
那個人資訊的部分的話
我們要去確認跟輸入的部分是什麼
第一個就是你的電子郵件
電子郵件的部分的話
這個很重要就是說
務必請大家把電子郵件輸入進去
你可以輸入你學校的公務信箱
或者是你想要放你私人的都沒有關係
主要的功能就是說
未來會針對於這一個公文系統
會有信件的通知
那就是透過這些個人的資料
來幫你們做信到個人的信箱裡面去
那比如說最簡單的是
我們最基本的會有代辦理通知
如果今天有公文
有分文分到我們身上要去做辦理的時候
那我們就會收到代辦理通知信
甚至公文如果說有相關的預期通知的話
那也會收到預期的通知信
那有些同仁可能主要業務不是在
跟公文系統比較相關
你可能久久辦一次公文的話
那我就更建議你們
一定要把这个email填上去
那这样才可以透过收email的方式
你可以知道说
你有相关的代办事项
你就不用说每天都要登公司
稍微看一下
那这个部分的话是电子邮件
然后再来的部分的话
电话的部分的话就是联络资讯
你在学校这边的联络资讯
然后还有分析的部分
也把它填上去
填完之后呢
我们这边点这个储存
就可以把资料存起来了
那再来的部分还有一个步骤
下面底下这里有个叫凭证
那這邊的話呢
以現在的這個要辦
以線上簽合公文的動作來說
我們需要用到的是自然能品
评证的加签
所以这时候的话
也要请大家帮我把自然的评证
接在你的电脑读卡机上面
然后点这个汇入
然后这边去帮你做资料的汇入
汇入完成之后就像现在
简报上看到的这边显示你汇入
就表示你有完成汇入的动作
那这个评证汇入的资料的话
系统会去记录说你这个账号之后
要用哪一张评证去做加签的动作
在公文系统的流程送出的时候
系统会要求你
请你把自然人凭证插到电脑上
并且输入自然人凭证的密码
然后呢
这时候会去做相关的一个加签的动作
那这个有加签的这个动作
是相关的一个规定
要去做处理的部分
这个没有办法省略
那这个加签的动作部分
你当下输入的密码
我们也不会去做储存的动作
凭证汇入只为是寄你这张卡片的一些基础资讯
个人的相关资料的基础资讯
不会去记录你的那个密码
所以这个部分的话
要特别注意的是
针对凭证的部分要去做贿赂
有凭证贿赂你之后才有办法
走线上签合的公文签合的动作
这边有一个要特殊说明的部分
是有关于卡片
如果你有更名或是卡片损毁
或是展期的部分
你的实质上的这一个卡片有换卡
或者是说你的更新资料之后
需要重新贿赂
那这时候就一样到这个地方
然后把原本的部分
就把新的卡片插上去
把原本的删除之后
后面再把它汇入就好
直接汇入就可以了
但是前提是有换卡片
像有些同仁他可能
赞凭证原本的期限到了
那其实凭证可以做线上的展期
你可以到内政部卡片管理中心
去做线上展期
那展期的部分的话
原则上他是可以做一个
展颜申请的动作
那申请成功之后
它不会换卡
所以基本上你就不用重汇
那如果说假设你是可能有更名
或者是说你的卡片有损汇
那真的有重新办一张的话
那完全不同卡片的情况下
就是要去做重新汇入的动作
这个部分要稍微来注意一下
不然正常来讲
你汇入之后就不用再做
调整或是做变更的动作
然后这个汇入的部分
你只要汇入一次
像我刚才前面有提到的
如果你的身份比较特殊
你有可能会用不同台电脑辦公文的話你只要匯入過一次那不管在哪一台電腦裡面用都可以因为我这个资讯是记在系统里面你的这个卡片的相关的一些基础
个人资料的资讯
所以他不用说像那个元件
是两个电脑都要安装
不用两个电脑都有做汇入的动作
反正你只要这个账号的资料
有保存期啊
有汇入成功
那在哪一台电脑都可以做
这个是相关凭证的汇入
跟个人资料的部分
好那再来的部分的话呢
是我们的刚刚提到的首页这边
那首页的部分的话
那这边有包含我们的这个系统的公告
刚刚有特别说明
那这时候如果说一些相关的资讯
要去做发布
包含新增的功能
我们也要去做一些bug的修正跟停机
然后还有一些教育训练的公告资讯
都会在这边去做公告跟说明的动作
那如果有看到的话
稍微幫我把它點進去
讀看一下裡面的資料
那注定是跟你
有想要攝取的資料是有關係的
那我們的首頁裡面
我們首頁的最右邊就是系統公告
有些人可能
都大概是常態性的
在用個人公文夾
他可能沒有特別去看
這個公告在哪裡
點首頁這邊的話
其實右手邊這一塊區域
就是公告的部分
這個部分要再稍微注意一下
好
那再來的部分的話
是有關代理的設定
那代理的部分的話呢
在我們個人底下
這裡有個叫代理的設定
那點開了之後呢
你會看到相關簡報這邊會看到的是
會把你個人的一些相關的權限都列出來
那你可以針對於說
你要被代理的職位有哪一些去做打勾
然後去做一個預約代理的動作
假設我今天要請假
跟著我明天要請假好了
那我就可以到這個代理設定裡面
找到這個資訊之後
把我要的職位打勾
正常来讲你们应该都大概只有承办人
那可能少数同仁会有登记桌
只是我现在示范的这个简报
它的值位比较多
所以我们下面可以忽略
那正常来讲如果说我们只有承办人的话
那其实只要勾选一个就可以了
那按这个预约代理
那预约代理之后呢
系统就会问你说那你的代理人是谁
按你的区间要设定什么时候
然后呢输入完毕之后就按新增
那新增完之后呢
我們剛剛是在代理設定的這一個分頁
你跳到隔壁有個代理資訊
就可以看到你剛剛新增的那一筆資料就代表設定成功那系統在代理設定的這段期間內呢就会自动的把你的这个公文的资料夹的读取权限
给你的代理人
所以代理人登陆他自己的账号的时候
就会看到你的公文
这边说明一下那个代理的一个机制
如果今天我请假
我把权限给别人代理的话
那如果刚好有人把公文送给我
那不是说在代理期间公文会直接送给你的代理人
他还是会给你本人
还是会给你本人
只是你的代理人有权限
可以看到你的夹子
所以他可以帮你办你的公文
概念是这样
不是说我今天请假
所以有人把公文送给我
因为我有代理的关系
所以他直接把那个公文送给代理人
不是这个概念
所以这部分也稍微做个简单的说明
如果不小心万一设定有错的话
后面还有按钮叫取消预约代理
点下去之后就可以取消
那这里还有一个小细节
我们的这个代理资讯这里
有一个预约中的画面
这个选单可以打开
它可以下来
我们看一下系统画面好了
这个我看一下系统画面给你们看
好
这个个人底下有个代理设定
然后代理设定里面呢
我们就可以针对于
我们要代理的部分去设定资讯
像这边的话就是我的权限
那我一样打勾
然后按预约代理
那这边就会有时间跟日期可以设定
代理人是谁
我们从主持住拉
那假设我先随便拉一个
然后按新增
那这样新增就成功了
那这里的代理资讯
就会看到有这笔资料
那我刚刚提的是
这里有一个预约中
下拉之前那一本集结束
那像我现在这个
假设我说要设定名片
但我设定错了
那我给他取消预约代理
那其实在已结束这边
一样会看到
我刚刚那一笔设定的资料
因为是我人工
把它设定结束
那如果说设错的话
就再重新去做一个
重新预约代理的部分
假设是这样
然后代理人是谁
然后按新增
那一样到代理资讯这边
就可以看到
相关的设定成功的资讯
那右边这里有单位代理资讯
跟单位代理的设定
这个是登记之后才有的权限
我们刚刚这边前爸有讲
如果说假设
你在是你要设定代理的时候
如果说假设可能有时间上的一个起迫性比如说可能临时要请假或怎么样如果你个人来不及设定的话其实可以请单位的登记桌协同帮忙
登记桌的话可以设定
整个单位里面通人的代理资讯
但是我还是呼吁就是
能自己设定就自己设定
比较不会错
因为你比较清楚
你自己要请假的资讯
这个是相关代理的部分
好
那代理期间的话呢
如果被代理人登出公文系统
那他这个系统就会自动解除代理的情况
登入系统
意思就是说
我今天请假
假设可能我今天下午要去外面开会
那我有设定一个代理区间
从下午的两点到下午的六点
是给我的同事去做代理
那这段时间正常的情况下
我不在的情况下
他可以透过代理的群线
读到我的资料
那假设说我可能开完会回来了
我的设定是两点到六点
我在下午四点的时候
我有回到办公室
而且我用我自己的账号
登录了公文系统
那系统会侦测到说
你本身自己已经登录了
那这个代理的设定的权限
他就会自动取消
但取消不是这一笔资料就取消
是你在登录的那个当下
你的代理就看不到
因为你自己本身已经回来了
那假设呢
你在四点半的时候
要离开办公室
那我们点画面的右上角
有一个登出的动作
点登出了之后
那一样你登出了之后的这段期间
等于是你已经离线离开这个系统
那代理人在我们设定的期间
还是可以看到你的这一个
代理的权限的资讯
这样的理解吗
就是你反正你本人登录了
就不会启动那个代理机制
那如果你在这个区间内
也有登出了
或者说你根本就没登录过
那他一样代理的机制是会维持着
OK
好
那再来的部分的话呢
是我们要说明一下
这个机关的地址制定的一个功能
那因为我们学校部分
就是之前有合校
那我们有两个校区
那我们有台北北投
这个阳明校区这边
跟新竹光复校区
那有时候你们在执行一些公文联系的时候
例如说我们用韩来举例
那韩的右上角啊
他会有一个联络资讯
就是你發文給對方的時候
要告訴對方說
對方的機關的承辦是誰
所以會有一塊
联络人的资讯
那这个也会呼应到
我们刚刚前面
个人资料维护里面
你的email
你的电话
你的分机
如果你有设定的话
系统就会自动办带进来
那再来的部分的话呢
是在这个使用者设定里面
会有一个我们的
自定的联络资讯的维护
把这个设定打开啊
我们这里可以去输入
我们自己的
想要呈现的地址
然后输入完毕之后
按储存之后
系统就会预设有制定的话
就会把制定的学校的资料把它带出来
那我们看一下系统画面
好
哪里呢
你就随便点一个创文
或者是点一笔公文进去都可以
好
到了这个公文制作的画面
那到了公文制作画面的话呢
我们就会有上面这个使用者设定的这个功能
那它现在叫你取范本
不取范本也没关系
因为我们现在主要是要看那个功能
那使用者设定这边打开
有一个个人化设定
那个人化设定呢
这里就会有一个设定联络资讯
如果你都没有调整的情况下
预设应该是关闭的
就像现在屏幕上所呈现的样子
那假设我今天是
我们要调整我们的联络资讯
那你把它打开
那你这里会输入机关的地址
那我举个例子
假设我这边要输入
我输入新竹的那边的校区的地址
按确定
那输入完毕之后呢
我们之后再做这个签稿的时候
我们这里
譬如说我现在要新增这个函
那以函的部分呢
它就会有一块联络的资讯
在有开启设定的情况下
这里会优先使用制定的资料
就是你自己已经定义过的设定资料
所以你会看到我这里会直接呈现新竹大学路
那预设的部分
那我应该要改一下
刚刚这边应该是要选台北这边的
那预设的部分就是
我们会有一个机关的资讯的设定
那现在预设的话是一样是新竹大学路这边
那制定的话反正
主要是让你们看出来就是预设跟制定的差异
你只要有制定的功能选项
系统就会预设是
是指定的
那如果都沒有
那如果說你沒有做過制定的資料的部分的話那預設就是帶系統預設的資料这个部分的话是有关于我们有可能会遇到跨校区办公文或者是我们一个学校
有两个地址需要发布出去的
联络资讯的时候
可以去做设定的时候去做使用
好 那我们等一下确定
你就会看到右上角这里
这个就会是根据我设定的资料
直接去做呈现
你们就不需要再改
不然有时候预设
像现在如果是预设新竹的话
那以我们那个阳明校区这边的通论
他就可能要去调整一下
那这样才会是有正确的那个联络人的资讯
这个部分的话是有关于我们制定通讯
制定地址的部分
好
那再来的部分的话我们来看一下
好我们来看一下公文流程
那公文流程的部分的话呢
在我们的系统啊
每一個文號前面
譬如說在你的個人待辦理
或是公文查詢的介面
找到這個資料之後
我們每個文號前面都會有個加號
一個加號的圖示的符號
這個符號是可以展開的
可以看到一些相關的公文資訊
公文的狀態
流程位置
還有一些相關的人員的基本資訊
好
這邊可以看到在哪裡
就是文號前面
然後這裡有個加號
點開之後變一個簡
這邊就有個相關的頁簽
有案件的一些相关的公文摘要
有没有来文的资讯
流程图跟流程记录等等
那你就可以看到说
那这个部分的话
可以看到这个流程的状态
跟整体的结果
那包含说你点文号进去
进入到这个公文制作界面
其实上面有一个叫公文摘要的按钮
点开也是跟画面一样
那就可以看到一些相关的基础资讯
那像这个部分的话
可以看到这个是流程记录
那流程记录就会致指
实质已经有发生过的事情
比如说几点几分
什么时候把公文传送出去
那给谁
几点几分
那这个公文流程
从哪一个人
又送到哪一个人身上
还是几点几分
长官有做了觉醒的动作
甚至公文如果有被推荐
那推荐的话
会有个所谓的推荐的理由
那也会看到说
那这边的话
你可以看到
这一个退成半人的选项
那他这边的话
推荐的话原因是什么
那这个部分的话
都会去写一些详细的
标示的资料
那你们可以透过这样的资讯
然后来取得说
那这个公文的状态
为什么目前是这样啊
那他的这个流程为什么现在是到哪个地方啊还是说他的一个被推荐的原因是什么都可以透过这个公文栽药里面的资讯去取得这部分的话是这个流程为什么现在是到哪个地方还是说他的一个被推荐的原因是什么都可以透过这个公文栽药里面的资讯去取得这部分的话是这个加号的部分
好那我们来看一下这个流程图
流程图要怎么看
好那流程图的部分
我们公文来讲基本就有成和会办学习
一些基本的这一个流程状态
好那公文送出去之后
基本上流程你已经给他了
你告诉他说你的流程要怎么走
要会办哪些
然后要怎么去执行后面的流程的时候
那系统就会自动产生所谓的流程图给你看
那流程图产生了之后
流程图里面其实是有一些对应的符号
好那我们来看一下符号的部分
第一个这个绿色勾勾的符号
它就代表说这个是已经完成的流程
比如说我公文送给我们的长官
送给我们的组长
那组长看完了他打勾
他往在下一个长官身上送
那我们的流程图在这个节点
你就会看到是绿色勾勾的部分
那蓝色一支笔的部分
就是公文目前的所在位置
所以你会看到
像这个公文
就会看到这个笔
是蓝色的目前所在位置
然后有一个灰色的
这一个三角形的暂停符号
那这个部分是指说
原本你在设定流程的时候
本来就会系统帮你抓
你对应上级的一些机关
或是单位
它会出现的人有谁
那比如说本来有一个
就简单来就是本来应该有它
但是因为可能业务上的编制
或是任务分配的关系
我们有时候会把一些公文取消
那像有些单位
他们可能有一些比较多的主管
多的一些简单主管
他可能只要负责某些部分的业务
那这时候我流程送出去的时候
我就会把这些可能业务
比较没有跟他有直接相关的部分
我把它拿掉
那我的流程设定完
就会变成这个灰色的
就代表是预设系统
本来会帮你自己抓
应该要经过的主管有谁
可是被人为的拿掉了
所以是预设流程有
但是被取消不跑的流程
那再来这个咖啡色
这个暂停的符号呢
这个就是指流程有它
但是还没有轮到它
所以基本上你们在流程图里面
看到的图示大概就是这四种
然后各个的定义大概就是这样
然后再来呢
你有可能看到同时
会有多个蓝色的笔的符号
然后到其他的单位去
那代表什么
那代表你在公文设定的时候
你用所谓的分会
分会的部分的话就是指我同时把这个公文把这个资讯丢给两个以上的会办单位而且有种分会的方式直接给他们那这时候的好处就是
这个公文可以同时给不同的单位
进行所谓的会办的动作
那达到一些效率的一个目的
OK
那这边的话要注意的是
我们如果是用分会的方式去执行的话
那分会它是没有办法执行退文的动作
我同时给人士跟主记好了
人士看公文的时候
他觉得没有问题
主记看公文的时候
他觉得有问题
你这个内容写的不对
要退回去
但是公文同时在两个单位里面
去做执行
人士跑到一半
主记也跑到一半
主记现在说想退
但是不代表主记要退
人士也要跟着退
所以在分会的部分的话
要特别跟各位讲的是
如果你的会办单位有多个
但是你的会办的话
是属于智慧性质
没有审核的性质
智慧性质就是什么
我只是要告诉他这件事情
不会因为他的一些意见
或是他给的这个意见
会影响到我公文内文的修正
就是没有审核意味的
我只是告诉你
基本上你大概都会同意
也没有什么太大的问题
那你又同时有多个会办单位的话
那你就用分会去跑
就可以避免掉要退文的问题
那如果说假设你这个会办
他是要有审核意味的话
那审核意味就代表什么
你有可能会因为这些会办单位的意见
去影响到你的内文
有没有要重新修正
或是调整在重跑的状况的情况下
那就不要用分会
因为这样就会变成是说
这个单位如果要审核这个公文的话
那他这样就变成是
他要退文的时候他不能退
他只能用取消会办的方式去做执行
取消会办的意思就是说
我这个流程不要走
那后面的流程会继续走
所以这边会看到简报有写
没有办法执行退文的功能
那必须要登记周期比较会办
那在会办的过程中
如果承办人要修正的话
我们要请退去原承办人
不是家会原本的承办人
我们的流程在设定的时候
你们可以去设定说
我今天要会办给谁
但是如果今天你是会办的承办人
你针对这里面内容的意见
你需要退回去给原本的承办人
请他调整完毕之后
再重新上乘的话
那这时候的话
如果你是原本的會辦承辦人
你會有一個叫退員承辦人的功能的按鈕
那就不是直接流程送出去
再把原本承办人拉进来
那这样代表你是要再加会他
加会是主于
会办都是主于知会性质
不是审核的动作
所以你会办给他之后他也不能改
因为会办的情况下你们只能给意见
是不能修改内文的
OK
这个部分的话是有针对于流程图
跟会办的一些基本的注意事项
好
那再来的部分的话我们稍微看一下
这边的话呢
去看一下被分办的来文
要如何申请改分
那这边的话呢
再讲的是说
如果我们收到了来文
经过确认之后发现
这个文它可能跟我们单位的业务
可能分错了
或者是这个业务不属于我们的
那这时候呢
我们去确认说
是非属于本单位的业务范围
那这时候就应该要
尽速的去申请公文改分
并说明理由
那这边要讲建筑的原因是什么
就是说你们要赶快去把这个公文设计改分
那因为公文收下来之后分给单位
其实它的时效已经在执行当中了
所以包含改分的这个动作
它其实也是有算在半年的时间里面
那我相信各位应该都不会想要说
假设之后真的有发生说公文要改分
那你是被改分后的那一个承办人
那举个例子
假设一个文到我身上
我看一看发现说
这不是我的业务
这不是我们单位业务
可能不小心分错
或是怎么样的原因
那这个不管
好那这时候
一般的公文收进来的话
它是收文次日开始算
六个工作天
我们以普通见为做案例的话
那六个工作天去跑的时候
我收到的公文第一时间
我也没有去做办理
我也没有去看它
或者我没有空
随便理由都一样
到了公文办理的第三天的时候
我才发现说
我这个公文跟我没有关系,要改分
然后这时候你就去申请改分
那你也把理由,然后这个东西都填了
然后流程也跑,假设流程又跑了一天
所以新的承办人拿到这件公文的时候
他剩几天?他剩两天可以办
那剩两天可以办,他就觉得很冤枉
这个文拿到我手上,我只是两天可以办
他到时候预期就算我的
我相信大家都不会想要成为后者的那一个成办人所以如果说假设真的有公文进来的时候第一个麻烦你赶快先确定一下这个业务是不是你自己的如果是你自己的那当然你很有余裕的情况下
你想要放两三件之后再办
那当然我们没有意见
可是如果说假设今天遇到要改分的时候
你看完觉得这好像不太对
那就看你们有没有办法
拨时间先去处理改分的问题
赶快把这个改分的申请送出去
申请完毕之后
那确定没有问题的话
那就可以去执行改分的动作
那就可以把这个下一个
就可以再把这个公文
分到证据的承办理身上
那你看一下这边有写
在办理勾选改分的公文
这边蓝色的框框可以打勾
上面会有一个改分的申请
那这边的话呢
去输入你改分的理由是什么
那他会跑一个流程
会经过你的单位主管
单位主管的在办理里面
然后去做一个同意的动作
那同意完之后呢
他就会退到总统人员
在进行改分的动作
所以这个部分的话
是承办人跟登记桌都可以做
登记桌如果第一时间收到
觉得有问题
那就赶快申请改分
那如果承办人收到有问题的话
那我们也可以自己申请改分
那这边要讲的就是
我们这个改分的部分的动作
要麻烦各位就是有看到的话
赶快去做处理
避免发生我们
我刚刚举例的那个案例的
这样的一个概念
大家都不希望成为那个公文被压缩的那个人
好
来的部分的话呢
我们讲的是这个自己创的公文怎么消耗
好那这边的话呢
我们把它分为三个情境来做说明
第一个是收文
收进来的文
或是来文要去做消耗
那来文消耗的部分基本上
它是外部机关发给我们学校
那这种文基本上我们承办的没有权限
可以自己去做消耗的动作
我们可以做所谓的消耗的申请
好
那这里的话呢
一样打勾
上面的话呢
也可以去做一个申请
那申请完之后
你要输入这个消耗的原因
那你
那用出去之后
系统会帮你把这个流程
丢给你的单位主管
那你可以看下面这张图
这个就是主管
有没有同意销毁功能的画面
他可以打勾之后
去按同意销毁
或不同意销毁
他是需要去审核这件事情的
那来文的部分的话呢
长官同意之后呢
他的流程会跑到总收文那边去
总收文这边会看你们的意见去看去判断说这个东西到底是不适合确定要消耗最后要可以就是决定要不要消耗这件文的这个权利是在早收身上
在那来文的部分
好那接下来的部分
我们来看看自创签稿的部分
那自创签稿它有分两个情况
第一个是如果你是自己创了一个签
或是函都可以
你要你这时候觉得不想要了
或是确定现在用不到了
那它有分两个情况
一个是没有跑流程
没有跑流程是什么意思
就是说我只是取人
然后放在我自己的个人代办里家
我都没有把它送出去过
那这个没有跑过流程的话
那如果说假设你已经确定说
那这笔文确定不用再办了
那你这边的话的动作是什么
一样承办人选消耗之后
输入消耗原因即可
那这个没有跑过流程的话
你自己输入完毕之后
这个文就消耗掉了
那消耗的部分的话
它一样会有记录
你这个文号
公文的文号只能用一遍
所以你不能说
我今天先取了
然后我不要了
然后我明天又觉得
想一想不对
昨天那个我应该要办
那我可不可以用
昨天那个文号继续办
不行
你已经消耗了就消掉了
系统有功能是查得到
你消耗的记录的
但是那个文号就是不能再用
好
那刚刚提的部分是没有跑流程
那如果说是有跑过流程的
比如说我这个公文送出去
送到我们的一级主管身上
他发现这里面的内容
就是有问题
他给你退回来
然后你们后来
可能又经过了一些讨论之后
发现他其实这个也不用办了
那什么样原因我们不追究
那这时候就是属于
你已经有跑过流程的公文
被退回来
那这时候已经确定说
不要办了
要消耗
那他的流程会比较不一样
一样你针对于这个公文
去申请消耗
那输入这个原因之后
后面他需要把这个消耗的申请
给你们的单位主管
就是要避免说
可能有一些应该要办的文
但最后没办
我举个极端的例子
可能今天这个一个公文送出去
然后你们长官也觉醒了
然后最后面
我也不管是什么原因
反正最后面你可能去做了续办
你觉得我不想要办了
我不想要发文
然后我就去给他消掉
这件消掉了之后
如果没有人经过同意的话
这件事情就不见
就没有人知道
我們身為廠商也不可能
你們有沒有什麼就是不合理的消耗什麼通常不會去檢討這個機關也不太会检讨这个但是如果说真的发生了这种应该要办的公文
但是被自行的决定说
我自己去把它消耗掉的话
那其实有时候会发生一些
比较严重的事情
那这个是一个比较极端的举例
只是要告诉各位说
有跑过流程跟没有跑过流程的部分的话
在消耗的流程的动作上
会有一个差异
大家要知道这样的一个流程概念
好
那已经有消耗过的公文
你日后还是可以到公文查询里面去查询
那这里的部分的话
消耗
主管就是会在戴笛尼这边勾选
就是目前这个画面
这个是自创公文的部分
对消耗的申请的部分的一个说明
好
那再来部分的话是我们的这个来文附件的超转
那这个功能基本上
大部分就是会用上来说
你可能收到一个来文
然后你可能要去做一个存查的动作
那你可能会去办一个签
或是办一个函
要去把它的附件超转过来
那你看一下这边的说明
签办来文的时候
如果你喜欢解附它这个来文的附件
跟相关的这个附件当做是
你这一件自己叫签合公文的附件资料
那这时候呢
你就可以透过我们新增附件这里功能
有个叫附件超转动的功能点下去
就可以幫你把這個來文復健
拖過來
那這裡的話
你就可以點這個來文編輯
選擇文別之後點這個復健
就點這個
旁邊這裡有8人復健
那個參考復健跟會辦復健
如果是函的話
那點開之後就會有這個
復健管理的頁簽
那這裡會有一個紅色按鈕
叫復健超轉
那點了之後
他就會幫你把這個來文復健
直接對應過來
那你們就不需要再去把來文復健
另外的手動的下載下來
然後再自己夾帶上去
有这样的一个超转的功能
好
那这里的话呢
就是我们要夹带的文
可以看到有超转过来的资料
然后按确定
然后就可以直接把它勾选完之后
按确定
帮你把这个附件直接倒过来
那你就不需要做刚刚上述的那些动作
那你就可以看到
中国大概是这样
就会直接把它抓过来
这个是附件超转的部分
好
那再来的部分的话
是針對於大復健區的來為復健
這部分主要說明的內容是這樣
你們未來也有可能收到
到來文的時候
對方他發文出去的這個附件
本身是有比較大量的空間的資料
那基於電子交換的一些基本規定
我們在做電子交換傳遞的過程中
如果今天的附件檔案太大
他是沒有辦法直接寄過去的
就像寄信好了
你今天寫一個信給對方
可是裡面有寫了很多資料什麼的
那你就没有办法用一般的信封寄给对方嘛
你就可能要类似要改用包裹方式
另外再寄过去
那这个的性质就大概是这样
那你收到这个文的时候啊
你会在这个来文的附件描述栏位
这边就会看到说
我这个来文是有附件的哦
那我的附件的话
请你另外到哪一个下载区
去做下载的动作
那他给你一个识别码
那这时候你就要去到
他指定的这一个网址
然后去做可能文号
或是试别码的输入
然后取得这一复件
那取得这个复件之后
如果说你们要再做切办的过程
你们要把它夹带到你们的
这一个参考复件里面去
然后如果下载的复件
大小超过20Mbps的话
你就用纸本的方式去做办理
如果说假设这个部分有超过
然后或者说你这个要发文的话
因为电子交换有一个
基本大小发文复件的
这一个大小的限制
所以如果你的答案太大的话
可能就要另外办
学校上要告诉你们说
这个部分的话
是有这样的一个动作
我们学校其实本身
也有所谓的大副接下来
就是我们要发给别人的时候
那如果我们要夹带的答案
是比较大的
没有办法通过电影交换
直接去做交换寄送的话
那其实我们会上传到
我们自己学校的大副接下来
也会呈现
文稿上也会呈现
类似这样的动作
会有一个网址给对方
那对方的话
就拿到这个网址
就一样会有验证吗
然後去指定的網址去做檔案的下載
這個部分是針對大附件的這一個
附件的夾帶跟一個下載的一個基本說明
好,那再來的部分的話呢
我們這裡可以看到就是有所謂的這一個
公文的群組
那公文的這一個授文者群組的部分啊
我們這邊主要講的是說
學校裡面會有一些所謂的常用群組
共用的
那针对这个公用群组的部分
如果说你们在使用这个名单的时候系统会问你说要不要展开那确定就是展开取消就是不展开那下面有示范取消不展开就写像这样
比如说全校各单位
它就显示这个群组名称
那如果展开的话
就是全部长这样子
所以如果说非必要的情况下
你们是要点这个取消
如果说你今天真的有需要
把这些新单列出来在文面上
那你就按确定
那这个看你们当下的业务的需求
如果说在使用这个群组的时候
看一下你这个内容到底是不是要展开
决定你的公文文面上会长什么样子
那再来的部分的话
是这个授文者的选取的方式
那授文者如果是正副本围他机关的时候
我们可以透过这一个栏位去搜寻
用这个关键字的方式
我们下面在授文者选取的页面这里
有一个栏位
它是可以去输入我们的关键字
那自己的部分的话
我们会有一个所谓的通讯路
那这个通讯路的话
我们系统每天会去帮你们做更新
这个机关通讯路会每天从公开的资料网站
帮你们下载下来并且更新
那在这个通讯路里面的资料
它都是可以做电子交换的机关
或是公司航号
那这个都是有去申请说可以电子交换的
所以你可以在这个通讯录里面
找到的相关资讯
基本上就都是可以做电子交换的
好 那我们来看一下简报上面
好 那像这边的话呢
我们可以看到说
我们除了下面这里
可以输入这一个关键字的部分的话
比如搜寻栏中搜寻这个机关名称
那下面可以自动显示的
像这边有个蓝蓝的好几个
那就是点下去之后
它是可以用电子交换
那如果没有自动显示的话
就是代表它没有办法
預設不能用電子交換
可能就只能走郵寄
好那這裡的話呢
是剛剛有提到的這個財務群組的按鈕
點下去之後呢
你可以再決定說你的群組要不要展開
那如果說你的受文者
是校內的單位會叫支援的時候
你可以點這個紅色按鈕
上面叫組織人員
點開之後他右邊會有個組織數
你可以看你要說確定這個文
可能還要需要再給學校裡面的哪一位同仁
那你可以把它加進來
那你可以用這個方式直接點
那上面也可以搜尋
那不要直接在這邊直接key
因為你在這邊key的話
不一定對應得到
就是說我們教職員裡面的相關資料因為目前現在給我們學校裡面內部的人都是屬於用公布欄的方式去做提供沒有另外再去用所謂的紙本或是電子交換因為你們如果是給各單位或是人的話
是本身不能透過電子交換的
所以這個部分的話
可以透過這樣的功能去做點選
好
那這裡有一個紅色的訊息
選取機關的時候
受恩者名稱
這裡的指定的人員跟單位
不要選了A之後
將機關名稱改成B
這什麼意思
我們來看一下那個系統的畫面
好
來我們這邊示範一次
這個受文者選取的畫面
我們從頭來
我把滑鼠移到正副本這邊點開
這種就會多一個受文者選取的介面
那這裡就可以讓你去輸入我們的受文者名稱
那舉個例子我們這邊輸入一下
我打了卫生福利部
那目前这边有呈现出来的
很多卫生福利部开头的机关
都是有存在在通讯录里面
那我现在点一个
你可以看到
它这边就会显示
预设是可以电子交换
就代表说
这个机关是可以电子交换出去的
这个应该没有太大问题
那刚刚简报红色这一块的名称
是写什么
意思是在讲这里
这里有个叫受文者名称
跟对应通讯录的名称
那我举个例子好了
假设我今天
要给
卫福部里面的
某一个长官
那我这时候我可能会在这边写
卫生福利部
我随便举例
某某长官
然后呢我这一按确定之后
系统就会呈现
一个所谓的受文者的名称
就长这个样子
那对方假设收到的时候
就会长这个样子
卫生福利部
然后是给孟国长官
可是这件文
交换出去的时候是给谁
他的对象是给卫福部
他是给机关
他不是直接给这个人
所以这篇的意思就是指说
我们后面有个栏位叫
对应通讯录名称
你这一个资料
这一列资料里面有对应到卫福部的通讯度
其实你这边全面要缴什么都无所问
但是我就是要给卫福部
因为你的资料都一直给卫福部有没有可能这样如果说你现在文面上这样
显示劳动部
可是你的资料打开
你的对应通讯都是个恶福部
那我这个文到底是给劳动部还是卫部
是给卫部
所以你们在设定这个资料的时候
如果你有需要去改收文字名称的话
请你们要注意一下这个对应的问题
因为你很有可能
其实是你要给劳动部
可是你的资料是设定到会不会
那这样是什么
这个文发出去的话
虽然上面是连劳动部没有错
但是这样
这个背后交换的代码
是给问出去
所以是会不会收到
会不会很奇怪
应该是不用
这个应该就是
所以这个部分的话
是有受文者的对应问题
我觉得我让他不要写的
线上的有什么问题吗
我觉得不要写才比较好吧
先帮你静音
感觉你应该是在讲电话
好
所以这边的部分是要强调说
你们的受文者名称这里
你们的称谓打了什么
但是你们要看到你们对应的资料是对不对
好像譬如说我们学校就可能很常收到
我们是要给我们学校某某老师
某某长官
他收到的时候就会是显示人的名字
但是他基本上他交换是给谁
还是给学校的代码
所以这个部分就是对应到简报里面讲的
选取机关的时候
如果你在受文者的名称
有家指定的人员
或是单位的名称
但是你要选了
但是你要选对的机关名称
不要选A的之后是给B
就像我现在示范的这样
你选A但是你要给B
这边有没有不懂的
有没有听不懂的
能理解
因为这个蛮重要的
因为这个如果说真的
你的文很重要
然后你的资料又选错
然后结果又没有发成功
那这个不会有人知道
他会不会成功
因为发文人员会按照
你设定的资料把东西丢出去
虽然你文面上是写
劳动部没有错
可是你对应的资料是给卫物部
卫物收到他就觉得很奇怪
他可能覺得這可能是發錯
所以他可能就問就不犯
當然他可能主動一點
他可能會打電話來問
但不一定
只是這部分要注意
就是針對對應
那我舉個例子
我這邊打一個
我打一個AAA機關好了
然後我按新稱
你就會看到我這邊打這個AAA機關
我的這個適應通訊錄名稱是沒東西的
就代表什麼通訊錄名沒有整理
所以它預設的這個發展方式是用流基
這邊應該就沒有太大的問題
好那我們回到簡報
好
那再来的部分的话
是有针对于
就是直章的一个调整的动作
那有时候我们
在公文送出的时候
系统都会去帮你检查
你有没有盖章
那有时候你又遇到是
我公文送出去了
然后结果又被退
那我想要重新合章
那系统的部分的话
如果你要把你直章跟意见删掉的话
你就直接到这个章之外
按右键会有一个删除的按钮
直接删掉就好了
因为这个问题之前还蛮多人问过的
或者是说你们点这个签合意见
签合意见也会盖章
然后跟写意见
如果说你这个意见要删掉的话
你也可以透过签合意见的这个按钮
去把它删掉
OK
这个是删除一个直章跟意见的基本操作
好
那再来我们要讲一个清稿
那清稿的部分
在系统里面
它有两种情况
会有不同的结果
我们要稍微知道
看一下它的定义
第一个
公文在牵半中跟决行后
执行的清稿结果是不一样的
这个效果是不一样的
这个是我现在要讲的
第二个
公文在牵半中
它的功能清稿
它在执行的时候
会把你的文面跟合章
还有相关的一些注尽
去做清楚
那你看我们现在点这个清稿
那我原本以线上牵合来讲
在披合的过程中
长官可能会去修改文面
那你大概会长这个样子
会有删除线跟不同颜色的字体
代表是要重新新增的文字
跟要删除的文字的一个注记
这个我们称之叫批合轨迹
那这个批合轨迹呢
你要去做这个清稿的时候
它会帮你把该删除的删除
该新增的新增
变成是一个正式的版本
但是你现在在签办中嘛
所以你的章啊
跟一些什么便利贴的注记
什么都会被清掉
清了之后
如果你的档案就存过了是没有办法复原的你没有办法说我清了然后我把东西重新送出去之后我又反悔我想要反悔成刚刚那样子可不可以不行
清了就清了
所以你们要清的话要稍微处理一下
然后再来的部分的话
它清掉之后就会变成这样
变成一个完整版本
然后你的招不见了
这个就是我讲的
它会把该三成的删除
该新增新增
然后把招喝掉
然后再来你可以看到说
公文决行后啊
它的功能名称就会改了
它会叫清稿执行文字
执行后啊
它只会是修改带路的文面
但合作不受影响
那画面会长这样子
清稿执行文字
那原本是长这个样子嘛
是有删除线啊
跟一些不同颜色的字形
点完之后呢
它系统告诉你是否清除稿面文字
它这时候就讲稿面文字
然后按确定的话就变成这样
该删除删除该删除形成
但是它裡面的這一個商就是保留的
你現在這個就是完整簽完最後
簽完的狀態的最後結果
所以清稿有分兩種
一個是簽半鐘的清稿
一個是覺醒後的清稿
這個使用時機不一樣
那結果就不一樣
接下來的話是針對於多稿公文如何批次的匯出
那這裡的部分主要是要去說明說
我们有可能会遇到所谓的来文
然后你要办相关的签办公文
以我们这个简报上为举例
你可以看左侧这里有来文的资料
这里有函有签
假设说你这笔公文
你觉得我想要把这笔公文整批的资料
另外存取下来
做另外的保管管理的动作
你可以到系统里面
一般有个批试汇出
有个汇出
汇出是指汇出你自己的签稿而已
批式汇出就是包含有来文
那如果说我们现在讲的是来文
跟你自己的所有签稿的话
那点开之后呢
系统这里会有个叫
批式汇出的功能的视团
那下面会让你选
你要来文跟来文的附件
签办内容的PDF
签办内容的附件
这可以勾
那这边要讲的部分是在讲
这里会有一个叫
汇出文稿的位置
這邊會有一個叫目前的文稿
還是要全部的文稿
你點開之後其實可以選
這你文稿有很多
那你可以針對於你想要
匯出的特定文稿去做構選那如果說你要全部你就直接選這全部文稿那确定系统就会帮你把你选好的条件譬如说有莱文
莱文复件
然后这里有你的
签稿跟签稿的复件
然后一起去做
这一个所谓的
我们汇出的动作
那汇出就会给你一个压缩档
然后在你电脑下来去
让你再自己针对
这一个档案去做
自己的管理的动作
这个部分的话
那是批次汇出的部分
那这里有写
路径的部分
一般汇出
然后汇出的部分
然后再来
你们有时候可能会遇到
WIN11没有办法
直接检视
因为有些附线是直接检视
JPG的部分
JPG的部分有可能是你自己本身
电脑去
那个检视器
没办法去看那个东西
所以你可以把它汇出来另外一看
好,那再来就要讲相关的公文流程设定的概念
好,那第一个我们来稍微看一下
设定流程的时候,我们组织中
你去点任何的单位或是人
去点两项,都是只要会办这个单位或是人
那如果你是要跨单位学型的话
是先点学型单位或是人
这边是指说你先在组织株先选到那个单或是人
然后再点绿色按钮审核
它就会把你加进来
这等一下会有画面
第二个避免业务调整等人
避免调整业务的情况之下
你们在设定会办或是审核的时候
我们尽量选单位不选人
什么意思
就是说你可能知道说之前这个公文是由谁会办的
或是谁批合的
可是你怎么知道他们单位业务有没有轮掉或干嘛
所以你们在指定要会办的这个单位
或是指定会办的批合的这个人的时候
我们就是用以单位为主
让那个单位的登记桌去分说
这个公文要分给谁
这样会比较准
我们就不用再去选说人要给谁
然后你要再去把那个组织数展到最开
然后再选特定的人
第三个会办其他单位的时候
当该会办单位
会办的承办人送出的时候
我们系统会自己去抓
那个会办单位的承办人的主管是谁
所以你们不用去设定会办的时候我一个一个把他们会办的流程都抓进来比如说举个例子我今天要会办人事事你们在设定会办的时候
你就设定人事事就好了
你不用去设定说人事事的一组的谁
一组的组长又是谁
然后他们的一级的主管是谁
然后全部把他加进来
不需要
你就点人事事就好
人事事这边登记桌
收到发分下去之后给承办人
承办人送出去的时候
系统就会自己去抓
他的职主长官是谁了
所以你们不需要额外去设定那些人的流程
你只要设定到单位就可以了
好
那再来第四个刚才前面有提到
分会的公文只能由登记桌进行取消会办
没有办法直接推荐给承办人
自己再看一下那个业务的状态去做使用
好
第五个是会中会公文
会中会公文什么意思
就是说我今天被会办了
然后呢
我发现这个还要再请别人再看过
所以我又再加会了其他人
这个就是所谓会中会公文
会办中又再去会办公文
如果说你今天是这种情况的公文的情况下
要退文
需要层层的退给原本的会办承办人
才有办法再退给公文原始的承办人
听懂吗
就是说我今天承办人是A
我留成今天会办给B
然后B觉得要加会给C
但C看完之后
他觉得这内容大有问题
需要请A重新调整
所以这边是写
如果C要退去给原创办案A的话
先流程需要退给B
再由B退给A
你流程怎么下去的就要怎么回答
这样才有办法达到流程整体的
这一个流程的引擎的动作
这个部分的话是要稍微注意的部分
好那再来的话是概念设定2
6当跨单位觉醒的时候
同时也是会办单位的时候
流程需要先点会办再拉觉醒
那怎么做
譬如说你的公文流程需要会研发处
觉醒的单位也是研发处
流程的步骤怎么做
第一个先选二层觉醒
我们上面这里有个选单
可以选几层觉醒
先选二层觉醒
第二个
我们找到右边的组织处
找到我们的研发处
点研发处两下
我们刚刚前面点先选会办
点两下他加进来
然后他告诉你研发数有会办
然后点一个研发数之后
綠色的按鈕點省核
它再把研發數拉到最下面
變成是覺醒單位
所以這個部分的話再按送出就可以了
然後這邊強調一件事情
我們的流程設定的畫面
有儲存的按鈕沒有錯
但是不用特別
每次設定完先儲存然後再送出
不用
儲存只是說
你可能想要設定完之後儲存完
然后可能要再重新回头
检视你的内容
有没有缺落
或是要再double check之类的
那你可以先用这个储存
把这个流程存起来
如果说假设你的内容都弄好了
你点这个传送
那你的流程都选好了
没有问题
就可以直接点这个送出
直接把流程送出去了
不用特别一定要存起来
好像有些人
我知道蛮多同仁
就是会有这样的使用上的习惯
就是说他觉得应该要先储存
然后再送出
其实不用就直接送出就好
这样也比较快
你设定当下是什么
那这个流程
就会直接按照这个方式
直接去做送出
不用特别存起来
好那第七个
如果承办的公文
需要会办的主管
那决行也是该单位主管的话
那公文就必须要
透过会避回承办的设定
再由单位主管
跑完之后去跑会办
去做第二次的决行的动作
好下面一个举例
承办人呢
他先给单位主管去走会办
那这时候我们上面这里有一个按钮叫这个
会必回承办人
你预设是那个会必成何
会必成何就是我会办完之后
直接往后面的觉醒的层级的人去做处理
那会必回承办人就是我会办完之后呢
跟我先回到我承办人身上
那我们刚刚前面提到的是
我要给这个单位主管去会办
但同时也是要他去做批合
跟上面这个很像
那这部分动作就变是
你要给你的长官
先汇给他的角色
汇完之后回到你身上
再重新发起
是有给他觉醒的这个动作
这部分的话
要做这样的一个流程的动作
这个比较特殊
稍微说明一下
好那第三个部分的话
是这个
如果公文的资本附件
是收续或合约不需要足及核這樣的附件的話你們就可以用線上簽合然后就可以用线上签合直接去做办理再来资本附件如果是你收据
承办人于设定流程完毕之后
可以先选择汇避回承办人
等到收据或者是什么相关的资料
扫描上传变成电子档之后
再到系统去设定决行的单位
这是一个操作顺序的问题
再来资本附件如果是合约或是公文
你在奉合后需要先将合约送给文书组用印的话
再早成去电子档案
那这时候公文可以先跑完之后
或去用续办的方式
再上传所谓的电子合约档案
然后再去做后续的归档的动作
所以这个部分的话呢
是我们的程序的部分
如果是你有要先做这个用印的动作的话
那用印完
你有得到完整的相关的资料电子档案
那这时候就要再去做这个
把完整电子档案去做夹带的动作
那你这样之后这个公文
听到档案是才是完整的
有这个公文的本文
有这个公文完整的电子档案
作为归档的内容
再来公文的正副本的发文形式
跟公文的签合方式
没有绝对的关系
我线上签合的公文
不代表我的对方受文者
只能收到电子交换
或者是说我纸本签合的公文
也不代表对方一定只能收到
纸本邮寄的发文
一个是我内部公文
签合的方式
我可以走线上
我可以走实体纸本
但对方要怎么收到
这一个公文内容
跟你的签合方式
没有直接的关系
你可以走线上签合
寄给对方的时候是电子交换
也可以寄给对方的时候是用纸本邮寄
你可以用纸本的方式去做签合公文
在签合过程完结束之后
发文出去
也可以把这个公文用电子交换的方式发给对方
也可以用纸本的方式发给对方
所以这个是没有直接的关系
好
那这个是没有互负影响
但是归档有相关的关系
该归档的东西就应该要归
那线上线盒就是要保留
我们刚才前面所讲的档案的完整性
去做归档的动作
这个是相关的流程设定
好
那再来的部分的话呢
是有关于公文预期跟展期的一些说明
第一个
执办人如果你只要预估到你没有办法在原本公文的办理签数里面办结公文的话,那你就可以去做办理展期的申请。那展期有分30天内的公文展期,你预计可能这个案情很复杂需要办超过30天以上
那就必须要申请所谓的专案管制
那我们这边先看展期
公文预期原先办日期的里面办结之后
如果你简单讲就是你办不完
原本先办日期内办不完
你就要赶快申请展期的动作
假设我今天有一份公文是今天到期
然后我发现今天根本就没有办法
把它办结案
办结案的意思代表什么
全部的流程要走完
如果你公文是签的话
那就是要长官觉醒完
然后你赶快送归档
那如果是含的话
就是要赶快批完
然后发文确定没有问题之后
再送归档
整体的流程
如果说假设我现在有个公文
今天到期
那我办不完
那我这时候今天申请展期
那长官也很快的帮我把展期的申请单都点完了
那也通过了
那假设展期展期天好了
那过了两天之后呢
我的公文办完了
那我也送归档了
那这时候呢
公文其实已经超过原本的现办日期了
那但是你有申请展期嘛
那你最后也在展期的天数之内办完了归档
以结算的角度来讲
公文预期结算的角度来讲
它还仍然是预期
可是你办理展期之后 系统不会再激吹你说
你这个是预期公文
然后再来你的公文办理展期之后
它会有个延长限办日
在延长限办日里面的话
办理公文的日数也是有累积的
比如说你本来是办了六天
你后来因为展期就多办了两天
那你的公文办理日数就是八天
好 那这个部分的话一定要办展期
因为这个办展期会攸关到你们后面
一些相关的预期计算
会不会列入相关的报表
所以这部分的话
你们要稍微注意一下
如果真的办不完
就赶快盛行展期
那这没有写
自账先稿的部分
如果是先你炒稿的话
就不需要先跑流程
可以多多利用炒稿的功能
你们可以把这个公文
就是编辑完之后
另存成立稿或是炒稿
那这样的话就变成是说
你真的要用的时候
再把它做正式的取号去跑流程
才不会说你取好之后
后面你流程要先跑
就不能跑
会有一些相关时效的问题
那下面這個是公文詐號打開
裡面會有一些相關的內容
你看到這邊會有寫
收創文日期是什麼時候
時效期算是什麼時候現辦日期到什麼時候有沒有學行的日期跟起案的日期这都会有相关的数据好那公文是不是预期该怎么看
你可以看到这里会有些相关的灯号
红底的话基本上是预期
那前面这个灯号就是预期的天数
橘灯白底的部分就代表通常是当天到期
就这一个
那再来绿色白底的部分这一个
通常就是你正常办理的公文
那你通常的这个数字
就是你可以办理的天数大概是多少
实际情形的部分
还是要看后面有个现办日期
因为这个时效的这个灯号
它不是无时无刻一直在帮你们更新
它是有个排程去帮你们计算
所以这个部分的话
灯号的部分是一个参考值
那实际上你们还是要看一下那个现办日期
但基本上应该都会是对的
除非说你这件公文
真的有什么特性的情况
然后再来你可以看到这个黄底的
像这一条公文黄底的部分
那这个就代表是已经决心的公文
那这个部分有一些基本的状态
可以让你们做快速的辨识的一个动作
好那再来我们讲一下
这是各类的公文的时效计算跟机推
第一个来文的部分
你可以看到说我们这边有这个起算点
稍微的次日开始起算
然后呢
集安的日期的话是送归党的时候
那这边其实有分
你是有发文的
还是你是有签稿的
那不会收到
自动激推的email是完成
那个答案是点收之后
那我们来看发文跟创签的部分
发文的部分的话你的起算点
是出二级出关
所以假设我今天这个文收到
我今天流程送出去的时候
送到你的二级出关
流程就开始计算
那集安时间是公文有去做发文的登记
送到发文人员去
发文人员登记的那天
就是你这件公文的起案的时间
那不会收到这个自动机构
Email的话是要完成点搜
发文人员需要在五天内
发文后帮你做送归档
这个是要配合起案
后五日内归档的规定
那基本上发文人员
都还是要等到发文过后
确定对方有没有收到
所以会需要一点时间
对方如果没有收的话
那我们这边就是要去想办法
让对方收到
有可能對方是比較晚登錄交換去收文
或者是他可能在收文的過程中有什麼問題
這都是有可能
但基本上如果以順利的情況下
通常應該大概是一天
頂多可能到兩天之內
就应该就送归党
除非有什么特殊的状况
再来自账今天的部分一样
你公文送出去的起算时间
送给你们二级主管
然后再来的话
结案日期是送归党的时候
所以你公文今天这个一个今天
跑完了
长官觉醒了回到你身上
不代表就结束了
这时候你就要去做送归党
假设今天长官觉醒了
然后你收到了
大概是下午五点
你到了隔天来上班的时候
你才把公文做送归党
那他最后的结案的日期
就是你送归党的那一天
不是在观觉醒的那一天
今天的部分是这样
那一样不会收到自动提吹
email的部分
是完成点收的部分
有一个起算时间点
来文的话是次日开始起算
创文的话呢
是出你们的二级出关开始起算
有分上午跟下午
公文的结案日期的部分
纯查公文的话是
承办人送归党的时候
一样有分上下午
然后再来就是发文的时候
是发文人员
去做相关发文登记的动作
或是送校园公告的时候
才是这个发文的
结案的日期
这个是相关基本的一个
时效的计算跟计算的
一个规则的部分的说明
好
那我们刚刚有提到
那个展期跟专案管制
那展期的部分的话呢
我们系统左边这边
一个表单申请
底下会有一个
公文展期的申请
那申请的部分的话呢
展期一份公文可以申请两次
最多可以延长15天
那流程的部分会不太一样
第一次展期流程申请的部分
承办人到单位主管同意即可
第二次展期的部分是承办人到单位主管
再上去会到一级主管
所以第二次的流程会比较严格一点
那方式的部分很简单
点到这个公文展期的这个申请里面
找到你要申请哪一件公文
点申请之后呢
会有栏位让你去输入你的理由是什么
然后跟天数是多少
那你点这个申请系统
就会自动帮你发一个表单
给你对应的出管
你不用设定流程
系统会自动办你当
那这个是公文展期的部分
然后再来的部分
另外一个是专案管制
专案管制的部分
这个就比较特别
如果你有涉及相关的政策法令
或是需要多方会办
反正基本上我们把它统称是案件复杂
那案件复杂
你已经预议要到这个可能
真的要办30天以上
才有办法去申请所谓的专案管制
那专案管制的部分一样代表单申请底下会有个招待管制申请单找到你要申请的公文然后点申请那一样呢这边会有一个需要申请的流程程序
这边就比较特别
第一个
详细说明申请理由跟预定时程
那你为什么这个东西要申请专案管制
你要描述清楚
长官才会知道说
你为什么要申请做这件事情
第二个
这里会有一个修改后的现办日期
你预计什么时候要可以傍晚
超过30天以上
但是你预计什么时候办完
这个是承办人要自己决定的
因为你这个东西
你要有一个基本时程
会有一个时间
所以你才需要搭配
你拟定的这个作业时程
的原因是什么
跟理由是什么
那长官才知道说
你为什么
这件公文是什么原因
什么样的情况
那预计的这一个
要办理的时间
是到什么时候结束
那才有办法去
帮你审核这件事情
好
那流程是长这样子
承办人申请出去之后
当什么单位主管
单位主管看完之后
到一级主管
那一级主管看完之后
还有一个到阻密
到阻密
OK
所以这边的部分
它的流程是比较严格的
翻管式的部分
尤其是针对这里面内容
要写详细一点
好
那再来的部分
是有关于自然能凭证的
这个签章付签的动作
我们刚才前面有提到
上签额公文在送出去的时候
它需要做自然能凭证的夹签
这个是有相关的规定
那如果说你的凭证没有带
或是疑似不见的情况下
系统本身是有一个叫临时凭证的功能
在我们的这个
我们看一下系统画面
在我们的个人底下
这里有一个叫临时凭证
点进来之后呢
可以去做一个借卡的动作
那这边就点借卡
那你的原因就输入进去
那比如说忘记带卡或怎么样
那你输入完之后
它就会有一个使用的时间
那使用的时间通常就是到当天的晚上
你今天借就是
现在是下午三点
那你三点借
就是到今天晚上的23点59分
那你在公文送出去的时候
就可以透过这个临时评证
先把公文送出去
当下先可以不使用自然能评证
那可以让他去把后面的流程
那这边主要要讲的是什么
这边主要要讲的是
你这个自然能评证
他这边在使用的时候
我们透过临时评证去签这个公文
这边是需要去做补签的
我们在个人公文夹底下有个代补钱
你这件公文有用过
他代补钱里面就有个建筑仪未来就要拿你的凭证回来补钱主管的部分會比較特別是單位的代补籤他可以看到整個單位裡面有誰沒有補籤
有可能是他自己 有可能是他單位的其他的人
好 那上面的部分我們來看一下
上述沒有品證卡片的情況是要補籤方式的一下擊中
第一個是你補籤
就是責任你自己有卡片之後
到你的個人工網夾代辦
你跟著代補籤的價值裡面去做補籤
第二個代理人接觸補籤
可以透过代理人同意之后
在系统中设定代理人
透过代理人的方式帮你补签掉
第三个是单位主管补签
单位主管可以到单位的代补签区中
协助补签动作
但理论上正常来讲
我们不会鼓励主管去帮忙签
这个是本来应该谁签的
就应该去做这件事情
主管的话在正式的规定里面
是有比较全责的主管可以补签
没错
可是通常是用在比较特殊的情况之下
比如说可能这个人他可能是约定的
他时间到了他可能刚好人就没有在机关继续认职
那他之前就有这些公文怎么办
那只能透过全职出版补签
这个是像是比较特别的情况之下
这个是自然能凭证补签的一个动作
好那有时候你们会遇到就是凭证
送出去的时候没有办法正常送出去
那有时候可能是你们的电脑读卡机没有跟电脑
就是有连接上的问题
我们遇过很多情况
我凭证明就接电脑上他怎么没有
但事实上就是电脑没有读到布卡机的资料
那系统这边有在这个说明档案下载里面
有放一个这个high cost的元件
这个元件不是我们开发
这个是内证布卡片管理工具的一个
原件可以通过下载这个
然后我们去检测看看说
你的电脑跟你的那个读卡机
是不是真的有读到
去做一个检测
检测它会在打密码
基本上如果你连不到
第一关就不会过
它是好几关
它会帮你检查
有没有凭证过息
有没有连到
过它就会打扣打扣这样
然后这边去做一个相关检测动作
好
那再来的部分的话
我们来讲一下就是
之前的旧公文到底去了哪里
那因为我们之前有做过
和校的相关的这个业务
那达到我们达到就是文档合一的这个目的
所以呢
我们有去做一个档案转置的动作
在这个系统里面
那档案转置的范围
就是已经有归档的公文
原本交大一福达系统的公文的话
109年11月18号前原本的话我们就是交大有一版是安泰的系统这是从一五达变成合校之前
中间还有一版是交大版的系统
109、11月19到11月31号
那再来的话我们原本杨明宁自己
有一套系统
在110年的1月31号前
那其实这两个就是一样
是正式合校之前的资料
总共大概有115万本资料
那这个部分的话呢
档案的转置都是有转完的
那你们查询的部分到哪里做
到查询监索底下会有一个叫档案目录检索
档案目录检索基本上就是可以去查
所有已经归档的公文的资料范围
那这里的话呢
可以去选择年度号
按承办人是谁
然后如果说假设你这边要查阅非自己的承办公文的话
那你不一定有那个权限可以去看内文
你只能看到基本的按有资讯
那你这时候因为选限不足
没有办法用的话
你这时候就需要去申请调案
那这个部分是需要透过调案的程序去做处理
那如果是你本身自己以前办过的公文
你可以看
你就可以直接透过这个所谓的
那个档案目录前准看到一些相关的资料
这个部分的话是旧公文的部分
那有人就问说
那上面不是有个公文查询吗
怎么不一样
那公文查询的话
基本上它是
我们看一下系统画面
好在下面这里
查询检索里面有个公文查询跟档案目录检索
档案目录检索就是我刚刚讲的
已经有归档的公文的部分的话
可以透过所谓的档案目录检索查到
已经提到档案室的资料
那这个年度的话是可以删掉的
那这样查询就会有很多资料
哪些年度的就可以看得到
那如果你不能看的话
你就是要勾选起来去做调案的申请
那会有调案的申请单
这个是答案目目前说
那公文查询的部分
是指这个系统上线之后
所产生的档案
你可以透过公文查询查得到
那公文查询查到
是指这一个公文
它在整体从产生之后
批合过程的记录
所以这个部分的话
你公文的流程
流程记录
流程图
就透过公文查询去查
那像以前的这些公文
那他就沒有那個流程圖了
因為以前的公文只會去記錄說
這個以前的記錄是什麼
就像圖書館的目錄一樣
你只會看到說他這個文他這個公文
他的存放的所谓的编号是多少
内容大概是什么
如果你的权限不够
不能看这本书
你就要跟图书管界
那如果这本书是
在你们的业务范围之内
可以看的话
那你就可以直接拿下来看
大概是这样的一个概念
可是就没有办法看到说
这本书当初它形成的过程
跟流程是什么
那个就没有
所以公文查询
跟达文件所本身不太一样
我会直接这样建议
反正你要查已经归哪个公文
你就用档案录解锁去看就可以了
好那接下来我们看下一页
下一页的部分的话
是在针对于公布栏的转发跟封存的部分来做说明
好
这位的对象是校内单位或是全校各单位的时候
我们可以透过单位的公布栏
那登记多的话
他可以去做转发或是部分转发
把这个公布栏资讯转到我们的个人身上
那这里的部分你可以看到
这里会有个所谓的单位公布栏
以登记桌的角度来说
它可以看到这里面的资料
去选择要不要转发
它可以指定
指定就是看我要指定给谁
单位里面的谁可以直接去做转发
那单位登记桌转发之后
可以点这个封存
上面有个封存的按钮在这里
封存后
其他单位登记桌
就没有办法在单位公布栏里面
看到这个公文
因为单位公布栏它是共通的
每个单位的登记桌的夹子是共通的
那你个人的话就是你个人的资料
那你个人封存的话
那就是没有影响到其他别的
所以有分个人的跟单位的
那以我们承办人的角度来讲
我们这边基本上
你大概就只有这个个人的公布栏
好那公布栏的部分
之前有后来有在做一个功能叫删除
那有些人会觉得说
封存是我想要把重要的留下来
那有些东西不要的话我想要删除
那你就可以透过这个删除的部分
直接把它勾悬起来
然后把它删掉
针对你觉得已经没有用的
那你觉得那些资讯可能
知识会兴致
没有需要保留的部分
你可以把它删掉
那这边就一样勾悬起来
然后这边就可以去做删除
记得删除的部分的话
它是没有办法复原的
那封存的话呢
它有另外一个以封存区
你可以针对于
就是已经封存的资料
再到这个封存区里面去看
里面相关你之前封存过的内容
好 这边有些
已经删除的公布栏
是没有办法复原的部分
这个要稍微注意一下好来的部分的话是我们今年度的这个优化功能的说明好 讲这个之前提醒一下那个刚刚有比较晚进线上的同仁
在线上的聊天室里面有个签到表记得去签一下
好
那我们来看一下这个今年度的优化功能的说明
第一个是承办人可以自行删除所有的创签稿
这个我等一下会讲内容是什么
第二个是公文在流程设定的时候
会有标示各流程的状态
第三个是指定的受文者可以用电子来文的资料
他可以透过公文系统电子邮件的方式传送出去
然后第四个跟第五个是针对于目前学校
针对于一些时效计算的报表
有在针对于这一些报表的内容去新增跟优化的调整
那我们来稍微看一下
第一个承办人可以自行删除所有的创迁稿
在之前有可能会某些情况是说我公文如果分给
承办人A
然后承办人A再看一看的时候发现说
其实这应该要封点我们同单会
承办人B
可是他已经有拟稿了
在拟稿情况下
他就想要把它删除成原本的样子
那之前的话以系统来讲
是会保留原本的资料
最少要有一个抵稿
但是后来经过学校这边的确定之后
需要把这个功能
就是弄成是最完整的
是说我们希望是把这个功能
恢复成最刚开始来稳
都没有情况下
那这样就可以给原本的下一个承办人做出一
你可以看到这边
你如果是要单位内改分
或是要改分这其他单位的时候
你就可以自己先把原本由你出来的东西
全部都删光光
那做法就是一样
左上角这里有个编辑
删除签稿
那你就可以把这个原本
最原本的底稿全部删光
留这个来文的资料
操作步骤这边有写
编辑删除签稿
按确定就可以把它删掉了
这个是承办人可以自行删除
所有的创建稿部分
第二个是流程设定的页面
有标示各个流程的状态
那这边的话你可以看到
各个流程状态我们这边有分审核会办觉醒
那就会像现在警报上面看到的
你公文在做设定流程的时候
会多一个栏位叫流程的类型
那系统这边会帮你标示
这个是审核的
那这个的话是会办的
这个是觉醒的
方便你们针对于说公文的流程的类型的一个辨识
那之前没有这个栏位的时候
你们可能就要去看
如果是没有会办的时候这个资讯服务中心在下面所以我是会办给资讯服务中心跟人事是这样那这样的话就会让你们比较好辨识这样的一个流程类型
这个功能应该上一阵子
所以其实如果说在
这个功能上去之后
你们有办过功能就会发现
其实有多这个栏位可以看到
而且有这个交易训练的部分
跟大家简单说明一下
那你们可以透过这样的一个类型
去判断说你这样的顺序
跟这个内容是不是
有没有什么问题
这个是流程类型的部分
第三个是这一个来文的部分
假设说我们今天学校这边收文收进来的时候
这个来文是要给我们的学校里面的某个人
某个老师某个教授
他有序名说这是要给指定的人的时候
目前现在系统有另外做一个功能是
这个来文我们可以用email的方式
把这个来文的资料跟这个附件
直接用mail的方式直接寄给对方
那这里的部分的话呢
有做简单的一个说明
第一个
这个文呢
你们就是他是知会性质
不需要办的话呢
那可能文书组收文那边判断
就会把这个东西收进来之后
直接用email方式寄给
我们学校里面的制定的人员
那email大概长这个样子
它会有这个标题
然后呢
激發的這個本文的附件跟電子檔都在這個裡面
然後再來這件公文呢
其實在學校裡面他還是會把它收進來
所以他還是有文號
只是說他發完給你之後呢
他們會做一個消耗的注記
所以呢在公文查詢裡面還是查得到
這件已經有發給你
然後又刪除又消耗掉的公文
那這個授文者的話呢
我們這邊如果說
有時候我們沒有
公文人員他沒有辦法去辨識說
這個文到底是要給誰
或者說他只能序名說
这个是要给学校里面的哪个单位
那这时候的话呢
他就会选这个单位
那他寄出去就会寄给
我们学校里面这个单位里面的登记桌
比如说我这个登记桌
我这个单位里面有三个登记桌
那三个登记桌都会收到
那登记桌看到这个mail之后
再自己去分辨说
他这个要再转发给单位里面的谁
OK
那这边会有一个简单的比较方式
优劣的部分
第一个我们以前是用这一个
人工纸本传递
那再来我们现在是用整合成email
那达到五指化的功能
那我们以前的话就是还要再印出来
那就还要再耗费这个纸张
还要再来就是相对的时效会比较差一点因为你又有人工传递的关系那现在就是相對比較快一點用email方式去做執行的動作那紙本的話你們可能還要再去做相關簽收的動作
因為你已經零零走了
那就要去做一個簽收動作
那系統現在可以達到線上查詢
那以前的話
可能還要再去做影印、掃描的轉發
現在就直接用電子檔案方式
直接發給我們的個人或是單位
所以現在部分有多了這樣的一個功能
可以透过email方式收到个人的
或是单位的电子来问
这部分的话做一个简单的说明
好那再来的部分的话呢
是针对学校的部分
有这个针对于公文的
有没有展期预期的建树的一个统计报表
统计报表部分这个以陈范来讲
这个你们不一定可以硬
但这边特别讲的是说
学校针对这个报表
去做相对应的这个功能的征修
然后现在有开放1、2、3级的单位登记桌
跟各单位主管可以产生
它报表名称是M818
那这边的话主要是会知道说
各单位的展期跟预期的建树
然后这里面的话它有这些数字
那它其实里面会有一些
可能需要去检讨的清单
那清单名细就是会透过
学校的另外两张报表
M819跟820
然后它这边会有一个名细
譬如说假设我这个栏位有实践
我可以找到819的实践是哪一些
那就可以把它列出来
那下面有个备注
统计的资料会随着你公文的起案的与否
譬如说你现在印的当下
你可能有一件公文没有起
那我就会算进去
可是最后面公文如果起案之后
你已经是用归档了
那其实他没有被NDS预期的话
那你到时候在做完这个动作之后
后面才产出的报表
数据其实就会各自改变
这边是要跟你们讲的是
他这个数据是会跟着当下的情况去做调整
好
然后呢
刚刚提到这个819跟820的部分
我们有新增报表里面
有新增这个承办单位的栏位
然后就可以对应到
我们刚刚前面那张报表
818里面的展期的建树名气
跟这个预期的建树名气
819是展期名气
820是建树名气
那透过这个统计报表里面的功能
可以去做相对应的这个练义的动作
有开放单位主管登记出的选先
可以去看单位内的相关数校报表
好
那再来的部分的话呢
是针对于系统里面相关的一些操作手册
跟一些功能系统说明的Q&A的话
我们会放在那一个学校的
我们系统本身的这个那个操作手册资料
里面可以去下载
那学校的那个
〔此段辨識失敗，約 1:30:00 起〕